Hi, my name is Nghia Tran...
...and I'm a coach here at Eastbay Badminton Association.
Today, we're gonna talk about proper footwork for beginners.
The equipment that you'll need to do footwork would be proper shoes,...
...a racket to play the sport and of course, a proper court as well.
Make sure the foot is turned towards the direction in which you're going towards...
...and not straight,...
...because you could potentially injure yourself and twist your ankle like that.
Make sure the foot is pointing in the proper direction...
...to balance your body in a proper lunge...
...rather than any other direction,...
...which potentially could help you cause your, twist your ankle.
This is how you do the footwork for the front step backhand.